A quantum entanglement experiment
performed on this satellite
showed that shared quantum states
can extend over 1,200 kilometers,
smashing the previous world record.
Quantum entanglement is physics at its strangest.
Subatomic particles like photons can be entangled
by sharing their quantum states,
such as their spin and polarization.
Even if the photons are separated by vast distances,
these shared states should remain in limbo
until one of the objects is measured or disturbed.
Then, the quantum states for both photons
suddenly collapse to a set value--
with no information passing between the two.
With fiber optics, scientists have been able
to demonstrate quantum entanglement on Earth
across a few hundred kilometers.
Any farther out, and the photons’ quantum states
are upset by fluctuations in the atmosphere.
But photons travel much more smoothly
in the near-vacuum of space.
That’s where the Micius--the first space-based
quantum research platform--comes in.
Inside Micius, an ultraviolet laser is split
and sent into a special crystal
that produces entangled photons
with opposite polarization states.
The pairs are then beamed down to earth--
5.9 million entangled pairs per second.
Two ground stations in China, over 1200 km apart,
receive the photons.
When The scientists, measured the states
of the incoming photons, they were correlated
far more often than would be expected
by random chance --
evidence that the photons had remained entangled
across large distances.
Although the transmission of the entangled photons
was much more efficient
than ground-based experiments, still, just
Next the researchers plan to distribute quantum keys
to the stations--
which requires long strings of entangled photons.
With entangled encryption keys,
two people in separate locations
could communicate secretly with each other
and any attempt at eavesdropping would be noticed.
Researchers plan to extend the reach
of the fledgling quantum network
by adding more satellites and ground stations.
That would be a stepping stone to a space-based
world-wide quantum internet.